Born in 1890, Hendrikje van Andel-Schipper was in remarkable health...
...until she died in 2005 at age 115.
She then donated her body to scientists...
...who looked deep into her blood to learn the secrets of her longevity.
Researchers found that much comes down to stem cells and their ability to replenish tissues.
When they wear down with age, becoming less long-lived and productive,...
...we lose the ability to regenerate blood and vital cells.
Our cells can only replicate themselves for so long before they burn out.
And by the time van Andel-Schipper died,...
...two-thirds of her white blood cells originated from just two stem cells,...
...suggesting nearly all the blood stem cells she was born with had worn out and died.
The research shows that genetic and biological factors trounce lifestyle factors...
...when it comes to supercentenarians.
And of course, it points to the potential of reviving bodies in decline...
...with injections of stem cells saved from birth,...
...which cautious researchers said is a real possibility.